earlier this week dr jarrah had a
one-on-one with parents to answer
questions about getting back to school
and the timeline moving forward one
particularly vocal group
was parents of seniors they want to know
how their students will be celebrated
when it comes to things like graduation
dr jarrah says for now plans remain
fluid
one of the things that we've learned
from kobe you've got to be flexible so
one of the things that now when the
governor's restriction
because we didn't have any venues now we
do there's potential
of opportunities where we're looking at
now to you know have you
obviously have an increase in graduation
class size
um that we can celebrate them so we're
going to have to go back and retool and
and revisit the entire thing
well as of now dr jarrah says he's
largely taking cues from the governor
and
county covid restrictions before any
large celebration or gathering
is set in stone kirsten dr jarr was also
asked about summer school as some
parents are concerned about their
students
falling behind and this is what he had
to say about that
one of the things oh recommendations
from the
from the stimulus money that's coming
eventually to get to get to us
is that there is some some kind of
accelerated mechanism for children
whether it's summer school or extended
year whatever we want to call it
we are early conversations around that
dr jara says as conversations progress
the district will let parents know
sooner rather than later so they can
make plans of course for their children
in just a few minutes the first in
person school board meeting in months
will begin
groups of parents who want to push up
that timeline for kids to be back in the
classroom planning to testify
in person they've gathered outside that
meeting being held at the las vegas
academy of the arts
we will have the latest from parents and
trustees on air and online with a live
report from sasha loftis
christian well with just four days to go
we will continue to bring you all the
latest updates here
on air and of course on eightnewsnow.com
now if there's anything we may have
missed
ccsd has a highly detailed list of
protocols and procedures
on reconnect.ccsd.net
very important website right there yeah
there is so much to digest
so go check out that website and ours as
well thanks so much for watching this
special back to school edition of 8 news
now at 4 we're always on at 8newsnow.com
and our app along with facebook and
[Music]
twitter